no he said he wanted women that were
based that is different that's based is
okay I don't want a feminist isn't the
same that's fine so yes I know Justin
Justin says you're like listen she's not
up to date with these policies
May differ a little bit like Justin was
like I don't care if my Girl Cooks I'll
get ubereats like he he doesn't care
about like some guys differ slightly but
the whole point is non-argumentative and
supportive is a must intellect and
argumentative inaugumentative and
they're not synonymous number one
they're not I the only reason why you
ever even see me in this light and even
when me and you spoke and he already
knows as well I can sit here and argue
and debate because I've got a mind that
can actually pick out the points that
don't make sense but it doesn't mean I'm
argumentative all the time this is just
for the context of the situation but